[Music]
if you thought looking for love on
television was terrifying
guess again some of your favorites from
bachelor nation are facing their fear on
fear factor this is everything I've been
through on bachelor and bachelorettes I
think today kind of topped it
our strategy is do not freak out how
would you compare the experience which
is more terrifying
that was scary for me too but this is
just even more terrifying I felt like I
was in a torture chamber
yet this was just how the teams who play
for $50,000 to a charity of their choice
include Alexis Waters and her sister
Nicole
Corrine elympios and BFF Gigi Vanessa
Grimaldi and Daniel Maltby plus former
Bachelorette Rachel Lindsay and fiance
Brian Alba solo I don't feel like we
just keep challenging ourselves we're
like oh that we passed that test let's
do something else crazy every target
they hit it'll turn off a fire bar are
you guys learning new things about each
other I think like we know at this point
like we were together so like I know how
he works so he was more calm than me
which is kind of how we are in our
relationship separate the men from the
boys how fun is it to do this with some
other bachelor nation folk though a lot
of friends here it's so good to see
everybody and we all kind of feed off
each other yeah it was I feel the
encouragement that I was getting from
like the people yeah is there anyone in
the bachelor world you'll be okay with
like never seen again
Taylor yeah but he lives in downtown LA
so so do I so probably will see him soon
so hopefully he doesn't see this
interview
you
[Music]